It's something of a cliche to say this,
but we live in a knowledge economy.
Increasingly peoples,
a person's ability to command a high
wage is going to depend upon having some
skills,
having skills that relate to perhaps
technology doesn't always have to be
technology,
but it has to be some kind of value add
that you provide that allows you to
command some pricing power in the labor
market.
Uh,
how you do that is going to vary from
industry to industry.
In some cases it'll be doing things that
computers do well as a data analyst.
For example.
In some cases it'll be doing things that
computers can't do,
a human touch,
professionals nursing and things like
that,
but whatever it is,
you're going to have to focus very hard
on those skills and the only way you can
get those skills through learning and
through continuous learning and any
company trying to hiring people will
recognize that probably the trade
they're looking for most is not a
particular set of skills,
but the,
the demonstrated ability to acquire
skills because any company will realize.
I think that what's crucial is not the
particular set of skills you have,
but that you demonstrate a capacity to
acquire them now because a few years
from now,
a few months from now,
it might turn out that you have to
acquire new ones.
Look at software programmers,
for example,
any software programmer knows that
within two or three years for almost
everything they're doing right now will
be obsolete and they will have to learn
a whole new language as it were,
depending on whether you're talking
about mobile,
whether you're talking about apps,
whether you're talking about traditional
computers and of course depending on
what the particular configuration of
hardware and software you're using.
So all that keeps changing,
uh,
in many,
many worlds.
And I think that because of the
information revolution,
it's going to happen even more so in
worlds that we don't usually think of
changing.
Accreditation's in some way are the holy
grail of education.
The reason that American universities
are able to charge the extraordinary
price they charge a is because employers
around the world believe that this is
the single best sorting mechanism.
They have to figure out whom to hire so
that if you have a undergraduate degree
from Harvard or war or University of
Pennsylvania's Wharton School,
uh,
a bank is,
particularly if it's in majoring in
economics,
a bank is going to think of the 20,000
applications we get for our entry 300
positions.
These are some very good filters.
We look at the people who went to
Harvard and wharton and Stanford and
things like that.
If you're looking for people who are
software programmers,
uh,
if they have gone to a good computer
science program at a good university,
you assume that's a very good way to
start to filter down.
And then you probably go through
interviews and things like that.
What if somebody came to a technology
company or a bank and said,
look,
I don't have the degree that you're
looking for,
but I did take 25 courses online from
these five online,
a core of Moocs,
many of which are Stanford courses and
Harvard courses and mit courses.
Uh,
and here's what I,
how I did.
And here is a piece of paper that have
pieces of paper that prove,
that demonstrate that I finished those
courses,
the grades I got on them,
etc.
If employers start treating those pieces
of paper,
those accreditation's as worth a lot.
That completely changes the nature of
educatIon because then you are not,
you know,
what you are being paid for is really
more outcome related.
It is related to what skills have you
acquired rather than process-related did
you go to a four year bricks and mortar
college and live in the dorms with other
people.
Some people may still value that ladder
one.
And by the way,
it may still be worth worthwhile for
some people to pay that because of the
network effect because of the people you
meet at a harvard or yale.
But you could imagine that,
that,
that would not be true at universities
one tear down or certainly two tiers
down.
Uh,
and in any case,
it would place huge pressure on the
pricing model because all of a sudden
people are able to access many of the
skills that,
uh,
that you're being taught in a top
universities.
At a fraction of the price.
so the key here is whether the employers
begin to view accreditation as an
outcome based process on skills as
opposed to a,
um,
a,
you know,
a kind of a process in which it's very
important that you have spent the four
years at the college,
uh,
and,
and acquired the full rounded education
that,
that college provides.